elle
bonsoir dans toutes les religions du
monde il y a une phrase que l'on entend
quand on perd un être cher
paix à son âme et bien c'est une phrase
que certains hommes ne veulent toujours
pas entendre ne veulent toujours pas
comprendre des hommes qui ont profané
ici dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi
plusieurs dizaines de tombes ici dans le
cimetière juif de carpentras la gravité
de leurs actes nous a incités à nous
déplacer et à vous présenter en direct
du cimetière une édition spéciale du
19/20 grâce à notre station de marseille
et à toutes les équipes de la 3 celle de
paris et de marseille
nous sommes ici devant le cimetière de
carpentras la porte est fermée depuis
16h30
elle le sera pendant le shabbat jour de
repos de recueillement et de prière pour
les vivants jour de paie pour les morts
c'est une tradition que nous avons tenu
à respecter
nous ne sommes pas entrés dans le
cimetière je n'ai peut-être pas le
moment de brusquer une communauté juive
encore sous le choc reportage de
marie-odile pas niaise et de jean-michel
destans la douleur l'incompréhension à
l'escale izia lisible et à l'egypte le
cette nuit du 8 mai leur mort on était
tué une seconde fois
alors malgré la tradition qui leur
interdit de fouler le sol du cimetière
entre la pac et la pentecôte juive
ils sont venus ici se recueillir exprimé
leur chagrin jusqu'à la violence
c'est mon mari c'est mon mari konan
vallée c'est mon mari est même pas
quinze jours qui lui manque
même pendant l'occupation que j'étais à
fort ici peut arriver des choses comme
ça de 2-1 aux morts et l'emballer mais
il faut les cendres palais à leur tour
vivant vivent les folies sonntag
dimanche le grand rabbin de france et
les plus hauts dignitaires célébreront
un office à la mémoire des morts bafoués
face à l'horreur et à la barbarie la
communauté juive sont opposés
la dignité reprendre tenter de
comprendre la folie d'un tel acte c'est
la volonté de la communauté juive c'est
la volonté de la classe politique
nous allons y revenir dans un instant
c'est aussi la volonté des policiers qui
ont commencé à enquêter
nous avons comme invité le ministre de
l'intérieur pierre joxe que tout à paris
avant de dialoguer avec pierre joxe
je vous propose de regarder le reportage
de dominique bonnot et de philippe bach
sur les premiers pas des policiers sur
leurs enquêtes reportages
deux jours après la découverte macabre
faite par deux femmes venues se
recueillir au cimetière de carpentras l'
enquête policière n'a pas l'air
d'avancer même si ce soir un jeune
skinhead interpellé avignon est
actuellement gardé à vue
les seuls indices restent toujours les
quatre empreintes de pieds relevées par
les policiers de carpentras depuis une
information judiciaire a été ouverte
le parquet a été confiée la sphère au
srpj de montpellier qui ce matin se
mettait en quête de nouveaux indices si
la profanation des quatre tombes n'a
toujours pas été officiellement
revendiqué les policiers s'intéressent
pourtant un mystérieux coup de téléphone
reçu ce matin par le quotidien vaucluse
matin
une revendication m'est arrivé ce matin
dans une agence d'intérim entre gens se
pressent vaucluse matin vous nom d'un
groupe mohamed el bukina revendiquant
l'opération conduite contre le cimetière
israélite de carpentras sans plus cela
n'interdit culture avec une voix
semble-t-il très prononcé d'après une
personne qui a reçu la plainte
tout ce que je puis dire il y avait un
texte qui s'accompagnait je ne peux pas
me prononcer là dessus
est-ce qu'il veut un texte qui
accompagne et la revendication non du
tout et tout ça sera exploité sans aucun
doute par les collègues du srpj de
montpellier qui encaisse en attendant
des résultats concrets la tension monte
au sein de la pilule au tjp vauclusienne
en fin de matinée un homme casqué kaboul
et a même été pris à partie par la foule
ressortissants britanniques son tort
était d'être un simple d'esprit est
d'être là à un moment où la foule avait
besoin d'un exutoire
monsieur bonsoir vous êtes à paris
nous sommes à carpentras merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
nous vous avons entendus hier nous avons
entendu votre première réaction
là je m'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur avez vous de nouveaux
éléments mais vous savez bien pour la
marque
les éléments d'une enquête menée par la
police judiciaire sous le contrôle de la
justice n'ont pas à être révélé
le fonctionnaire que vous menez
d'interviewer vient de commettre une
faute professionnelle
c'est la justice qui doit punir les
coupables
la police l'aide et pour l'aider elle a
besoin de secret l'arrestation du ski
net vous semble plausible crédible je
vous répète que dans une affaire comme
celle là les fonctionnaires de la police
sont extrêmement motivés pour trouver
les coupables j'ai vu ce qui était sur
place au cimetière de carpentras que
vous avez vu vous même aujourd'hui et
l'horreur des faits la violence qu'elle
révèle fait que les fonctionnaires et
les magistrats qui sont chargés de cette
enquête l'amène comme ils le doivent
c'est à dire en respectant les règles
professionnelles qui suppose le secret
je m'adresse maintenant à l'homme
politique que vous êtes
monsieur joxe qui est responsable qui
est responsable des actes même c'est pas
un homme politique qui peut vous le dire
c'est un magistrat ou des magistrats qui
auront à en juger en fonction de ce
fruit nous aurons pu trouver vous avez
compris le sens de ma question est
présent sollicité moral voilà de ceux
qui diffusent des idées racistes mais la
responsabilité morale de ceux qui n'ont
peut-être pas assez lutter contre le
racisme moi même je suis prêt à assumer
la responsabilité de d'avoir toujours
lutter contre le racisme n'est pas assez
lorsque nous avons pensé qu'il fallait
diffuser dans les écoles des
enseignements pour attirer l'attention
des jeunes sur les dangers du racisme
peut être que nous n'avons pas fait
assez je pense que lorsque le président
l'a vu ligue dit que les français
doivent se ressaisir
il s'adresse à tous les français ceux
qui peuvent avoir des inclinations à se
laisser aller à exprimer des sentiments
racistes qui va se ressaisir et aussi
tous ceux qui sont des démocrates et qui
pensent qu'il faut lutter contre le
racisme et qui doivent tous se dire
comment faire pour que de telles idées
ne se développe pas en france c'est pour
que là où elles apparaissent elles
soient combattues par les idées comment
faire pour faire retomber suffisamment
de honte sur ce qu'ils diffusent ces
idées dont on se souvient en tout cas ce
qui était enfant ou adulte a fortiori
pendant la guerre savent que le racisme
l'intolérance peuvent conduire à des
crimes épouvantables irib lutter contre
ces ide il il y a des silences lourds de
sens
vous avez cité ce matin le nom de
l'homme politique jean-marie le pen est
il dans une certaine mesure responsable
indirectement
qui peut penser que le discours raciste
soit innocent merci monsieur joxe
comprendre tenter de comprendre nous
avons nous aussi tenté de le faire c'est
le reportage de nathalie darrigrand et
de aimé poupart qui se sont rendus dans
la ville de carpentras aujourd'hui à
deux pas d'ici
une ville tranquille où la communauté
juive est parfaitement intégré et là on
ne comprend pas reportage
7h ce matin le marché s'installe en
plein centre ville comme tous les
vendredis car quand on est tranquille et
pourtant soit toute la ville ne parle
que de tombes profanées
c'est un homme voit ce qui s'est passé
c'est des choses est déplorable
catastrophique
c'est ignoble ça me rappelle il ya 45
ans j'étais encore jeune et enfin j'ai
pas oublier tous vraiment à être eu mais
surtout ça l'indignation est unanime est
d'autant plus forte qu'ici la
cohabitation entre les différentes
communautés s'est toujours bien passé et
notamment avec les 80 familles juives
qui habite la ville c'est la
consternation c'est c'est le dégoût
c'est la colère c'est la honte
communauté juive et une communes
communautés totalement intégré ils sont
ici depuis on l'a dit depuis le xiiie
siècle
il ya des familles qui sont
carpentrassienne depuis plusieurs
centaines d'années
bon il n'y a aucun problème à ce niveau
là ni gecko ni exclusion ni racisme
pas plus qu'ailleurs répondent les
carpentrassiens ici comme dans tout le
sud est de la france le front national
est bien implanté mais jamais deux
manifestations violentes ou racisme bio
auparavant ce soir le conseil municipal
tient une réunion extraordinaire pour
réaffirmer son soutien à la communauté
juive
cet acte commis ici à carpentras est
spectaculaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous diffusions cette édition
spéciale mais il faut savoir que dans
les dernières semaines et derniers mois
d'autres profanation été commises dans
d'autres cimetières juifs car sébastien
y at il une france de l'antisémitisme et
des périodes où celui-ci ressurgit plus
volontiers difficile à dire mais depuis
dix ans nombreux sont les actes commis
contre la communauté juive et ses
symboles cible privilégiée les
synagogues et les cimetières
ainsi en décembre 83 40 tombes seront
profanées dans un bourg de la banlieue
de strasbourg
à cette époque là on refusait de croire
à un acte antisémite
moi je crois d'abord que ce sont des
actes de vandalisme novembre 84,64
tombes sont détruites à coups de masse
dans le cimetière de nice mais 87 c'est
autour du cimetière de créer en
haute-saône de faire l'objet de
déprédations avril 88 pts weiler 90
comme sont saccagées par trois
adolescents mais 80
8 67 elles sont détruites dans un
cimetière du bas-rhin néonazis skinhead
ou adolescent paumé toujours la même
haine
celle qui détruira plusieurs synagogues
en 89
comme ici à rouen c'est lucky à
carpentras vient de franchir un nouveau
stade dans l'horreur de cette sinistre
litanie je faisais tout à l'heure
allusion au non dit et on a écouté on
entendu pierre joxe tout le monde tout
les hommes politiques pensent à l'un
d'entre eux jean marie le pen
même si personne ne prononce son nom
jean marie le pen le sait il a tenu à
réagir au cours d'une conférence de
presse cet après midi réaction de daniel
sporting euros cueillis par deniz bank
et l'eau je considère qu'on nous fait là
un un procès tout à fait injuste
un véritable procès des sorcières is
fait site cui prodest celui-là l'a fait
à qui cela profite
cela devrait en tout cas écarté le front
national 1
on ne voit pas le front national faisant
quelque chose d'aussi ignoble pour
déclencher contre lui l'unanimité de ses
adversaires et bien moi je pense qu'il
faut tout de même chercher soit du côté
des communistes qui semblent être les
maîtres d'oeuvre de toute cette
opération avec l'orge courroie de
transmission le mrap
c'est eux qui ont mis en oeuvre la loi
la proposition de loi c'est eux qui ont
animé les manifestations hostiles à ma
présence à l'heure de vérité et c'est
eux qui essayent d'orchestrer la
réaction d'indignation populaire autour
des affaires de carpentras mais ce
pourrait être aussi des mouvements
subversifs islamique dont on sait qu'ils
ne portent pas spécialement dans leur
coeur les juifs n'est ce pas la vivacité
des réactions des unes et des autres
illustre en tout cas le climat politique
qui règne en france un climat sur toile
de fond raciste ou sur toile de fond
violente un homme a tenu à y faire
allusion aux hommes qui a tenu à se
rendre ici dans le cimetière juif de
carpentras et les wiesel prix nobel de
la paix témoignage
payé par jean-michel destans j'imagine
qu'il s'agit d'une action organisée et
préméditée
il ya quelque part des gens ici en
france où peu partout
sheen ne peuvent pas à moi
les jeter vivants au bras
soit quand
corps
ce qui me touche et pierre très beau
de très nombreux hommes politiques de
droite et de gauche sont venus ici se
recueillir dans le cimetière juif de
carpentras nous les entendrons peut-être
tout à l'heure mais il ya eu aussi
d'autres réactions politiques à paris
que vous avez recueilli élise on est
aujourd'hui pc ps udc udf rpr et fn tous
les milieux politiques condamne de
manière unanime la profanation des
tombes de carpentras on l'a vu certaines
personnalités ont tenu à se rendre sur
les lieux et tous même à paris on réagit
a commencé par une minute de silence à
l'assemblée nationale fait suspendre la
séance sera reprise milhas silence à
l'assemblée nationale suspension de
séance au sénat
l'ensemble de la classe politique a
condamné toute la journée
l'acte odieux de carpentras
ce sont à la fois des des actes qui
touchent une communauté importante de
notre vie nationale et en même temps qui
profanent les tombes des morts
ils devront penser à la région de même
que la meilleure façon de manifester
notre solidarité c'était de contribuer
nous mêmes à la restauration des tombes
profanées la montée de l'intolérance
dans notre pays depuis une dizaine
d'année oblige tous les hommes
politiques
à s'interroger sur leur propre
responsabilité
ont-ils toujours fait tout ce qui était
nécessaire pour empêcher le
développement de ce fléau
alors monde politique est unanime on l'a
vu au moins dans la condamnation cette
profanation alors michel de merde
question les hommes politiques
oublierait-il ont aussi leurs vieux
démons
oui le premier jour était avant tout
marquée par l'indignation il on comprend
aujourd'hui s'y ajoute une sorte de
prise de conscience finalement
carpentras et l'horreur qui s'ajoute à
l'inacceptable mail est inacceptable il
est là au quotidien
on le trouve à travers un slogan un
tract des déprédations et on s'aperçoit
que depuis quelques années effectivement
les signes de l'antisémitisme sur fond
de crise se multiplient en france et on
prend conscience que le racisme au fond
est une sorte de longues chez nous
chaque maillon même apparemment le plus
anodin à son apparat son importance et
que chaque propos d'exclusion chaque
propos de haine ou d'acceptation de
thèses révisionnistes accentue prolonge
enrichi cette chaîne par la classe
politique montre du doigt ceux qui
mettent des bûches de temps à autre sur
le brasier de l'antisémitisme et jean
marie le pen est vraiment isolé quand il
évoque des thèses sur les machinations
on l'a vu ces derniers mois que
s'esquissait une sorte de front du refus
un consensus sur l'anti racisme qui
avaient du pc au rpr mais il a été
constamment me brouiller par des
préoccupations tactique je crois qu'on
est en droit aujourd'hui d'attendre de
nos hommes politiques que ses
préoccupations tactique le s'efface
derrière le mur du cimetière de
carpentras on en perçoit les premiers
signes par exemple gérard longuet qui
n'est pas complaisant à l'égard de la
gauche demande que l'on retourne à la
table ronde sur l'immigration c'est un
premier signe
il y aura d'autres dans les prochains
jours merci michel voilà pour les
réactions politiques et vous l'imaginez
le monde
religieux dans son ensemble a lui aussi
dénoncé l'horreur de cet acte le
cardinal lustiger a demandé une journée
de pénitence et de jeunes communautés
contemplatives
le recteur de la grande mosquée de paris
condamne de toutes ses forces cet acte
criminel
enfin le père di falco a estimé ce matin
que les discours qui exacerbe le racisme
sont indignes des hommes politiques
mobilisation énorme dès aujourd'hui avec
des manifestations partout en france et
en province sites en province mais aussi
à paris où un millier de lycéens et
d'étudiants se sont recueillis
spontanément devant le mémorial juifs
ce soir la communauté israélite s'est
donné rendez vous à la grande synagogue
de la victoire paris pour prier que
m'ont rejoint tout de suite
morad aït habbouche si tout au long de
la journée les réactions se sont
multipliées les mots se sont bousculés
pour condamner cet acte horreur nausées
d'ego révolution colère ici à la
synagogue de la victoire
un seul discours une seule réponse le
silence le recueillement
michel rocard le premier ministre est
venu témoigner sa solidarité ou en
rabbin et à la communauté israélite
il n'a pas dit un mot d'autres
personnalités sont attendues
des centaines de personnes sont encore à
l'intérieur elle prit dans moins de
vingt minutes
à la tombée de la nuit ce sera le
shabbat plus que jamais un jour férié de
recueillement enfin dernière information
les organisations juives laïques et
religieuses ont appelé à une marche
silencieuse mercredi à 19 heures rendez
vous place de la concorde
le cortège se rendra ensuite à la
synagogue de la victoire ici même où un
office sera célébrée elle est monsieur
et assemblons bien le convient de le
voir dans la communauté juive pour
preuve encore cette rencontre ce matin
entre les élèves du lycée turgot et deux
ex déportés 2,8 pour ces jeunes une
seule réaction
l'incompréhension pro portage ambroise
perrin du baron avait il n'avait même
pas cependant j'ai vu mon frère et dix
neuf ans j'ai eu ma soeur qui était sa
jumelle 19,6 ils avaient leur âge en
1944 il est élève au lycée turgot dans
le 3e arrondissement de paris
aujourd'hui ces deux rescapés
d'auschwitz tiennent à apporter leur
témoignage au coeur du marais au lycée
turgot le tiers des élèves et des
professeurs font de confession israël
ce débat est né spontanément ce matin
dans la cour de récréation plus que
l'indignation c'est l'incompréhension et
la peur du retour de l'antisémitisme
puis la guerre c'est pas il ya
pleinement pour des pour dire sa rebelle
c'est horrible sourire et dans la cei un
les jeunes peuvent changer quelque chose
sûrement sûrement mais quand il voit les
les aînés agir comme ils le font moi la
pl à leur place si j'avais leur âge je
ne serais pas très fier des gens de
notre âge
enfin un dernier point sur cette affaire
au point historique le soin de
carpentras pour cette odieuse
profanation n'est certainement pas un
hasard
la ville est en effet un véritable
symbole pour la communauté juive c'est
l'un des berceaux de la civilisation
juive en france
explications à nouveau carpentras
berceau du judaïsme français première
ville d'adoption de la communauté juive
dès le début de l'ère chrétienne une
communauté renforcer xiv e siècle plus
tard par l'arrivée des expulsés du
royaume de france
un certain nombre de réfugiés vont alors
s'installer à avignon carpentras
cavaillon et l'isle sur sorgue
c'est quatre communautés qu'on appelait
les quatre cinq communautés étaient
placés en effet sous domini ça sous
domination pontificale les juifs étaient
donc des juifs du pas et même s'il était
astreint au port d'un signe distinctif
ils pouvaient vivre exercer leur culte
malgré la protection papale la
communauté juive de carpentras toléré
sans être intégrés a souvent été la
proie de persécution diverses accusés
d'avoir propagé la peste en 1343 les
juifs sont victimes cent ans plus tard
d'un premiers pogroms
c'est la naissance de la carrière le
ghetto dans lequel la communauté et
boucler chaque soir exclu de la plupart
des professions condamné au port du
chapeau jaune au xvième siècle les juifs
doivent en cours s'incliner devant
l'évêque de carpentras la plus vieille
synagogue de france est jugé trop belle
et surtout trop haute
elle sera en partie rasé arrive enfin la
révolution française les descendants des
juifs du pape deviennent citoyens à part
entière et déserte progressivement la
région reste la tradition beaucoup
reviennent encore se recueillir et se
faire enterrer dans la ville qu'ils
considèrent comme la jérusalem de france
le reste de l'actualité maintenant avec
la roumanie où la situation est toujours
tendue à quelques jours des élections le
climat s'alourdit aujourd'hui 2000
partisans du front de salut national ont
manifesté à bucarest mais dans le même
temps les américains rappelé leurs
ambassadeurs
il estime que les conditions de la
démocratie ne semblent pas réunies
francine vraiment l'uqar est ce matin à
2000 roumain manifestent leur
attachement à la tenue d'élections le 20
mai prochain
contrairement à ceux qui occupent la
place de l'université depuis presque
deux semaines ils pensent eux que seul
le programme du front de salut national
apportera la prospérité au peuple
roumain
ils demandent à leurs dirigeants de ne
pas céder aux pressions des groupes
minoritaires et apolitique mais alors
que se déroule cette
contre-manifestation un des trois partis
d'opposition le parti national paysans
décide de se retirer de la coalition
gouvernementale pour protester contre
les agressions et intimidations dont ont
fait l'objet ces derniers jours les
leaders de l'opposition
enfin le gouvernement américain rappel
pour consultation son ambassadeur à
bucarest faisant état d'irrégularités
dans le déroulement de la campagne dans
dix jours doivent avoir lieu les
premières élections libres en roumanie
depuis cet après midi la télévision
roumaine n'est plus sous l'autorité du
seul front de salut national
c'était l'une des principales
revendications des manifestants de la
place de l'université
tout de suite les autres faits marquants
de l'actualité en france et à l'étranger
pascal justice
au moins 18 morts et 16 blessés dans un
accident d'avion au sud est du mexique
l'appareil transportait des pèlerins qui
allait voir le pape il s'est écrasé en
atterrissant au compte parmi les
victimes
un évêque et des fonctionnaires du
gouvernement mexicain
hot accidents d'avion aux philippines
cette fois un boeing 737 a pris feu au
décollage à manille bilan provisoire
sept morts et 80 blessés dont 22
grièvement
on ignore encore les causes de
l'explosion à l'origine de l'accident
mais l'hypothèse d'un attentat n'est pas
exclue
c'est ici dans les cités de la courneuve
en région parisienne que les policiers
du raid ont tiré et tué un forcené
dominique hoé avait 48 ans il avait
menacé sa femme avec une arme elle avait
réussi à s'enfuir et à prévenir la
police
toute la nuit les négociations ont
échoué alors au petit matin les
policiers sont entrés de force
l'homme en a blessé quatre aux jambes
ils ont riposté un nouveau mouvement
écologique est né s'appelle génération
écologie son fondateur brice lalonde
sp ses motivations je suis pour agir pas
pour gémir voilà et moi je ne suis pas
pour l'écologie douze n'est ce pas qui
va se retirer dans sa tente en disant je
suis contre tout débrouillez-vous pas du
tout il faut agir je suis pour
l'écologie réaliste et constructive
son objectif est de se battre pour des
causes dit yves et de présenter des
candidats aux élections même s'ils
restent vous me garantir qu'il n'y a pas
la main du colonel victor la culotte de
génération écologie je ne peux pas c'est
comme ça voilà
clôture aujourd'hui du congrès sur l'eau
qui réunissait à paris les maires de
france
michel rocard est venu soutenir leur
action ils s'engagent à aider à la
modernisation des systèmes en place pour
la distribution d'un lien de venir à
l'eau au festival de cannes après la
grande soirée d'ouverture hier sur l'a3
présentation aujourd'hui du film de
monica vitti scandale au segreto monica
vitti réalisatrice pour ce film projeté
en ouverture de la sélection un certain
regard
reportage dominique penser philippe
basquin la viti à cannes la vie qui à
cannes et cette fois ci pas en tant que
simple comédienne mais en tant que
créateur à part entière et elle est
visiblement émue la muse d'antonioni de
présenter son film son bébé comme elle
dit puisque le porta pendant exactement
neuf mois et qu'aujourd'hui ce
nouveau-né concourt pour la caméra d'or
jamais un kit complet mais pendant une
heure on a des preuves
il suffit qu'elle passe et alors je
commençais existe des dialogues en
bulles femme elle nomme et une petite
bagarre mais les points je savais que la
science et l open
bien faire avec sow et la même temps on
est proposée est la mecque médine et et
sinon j'espère très légumes petites
histoires qui voudraient à petit nous
arriver parce qu'on a le secret c'est
une histoire d'amour banale ébranlé un
matin par une intruse qui voit tout
entend tout et révèle tout une intruse
qui vous l'avez compris bien sûr n'est
rien d'autre qu'une caméra
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'actualité
parfois très lourdes de ce vendredi pour
refermer journal nous rejoignons tout de
suite paul amar en direct du cimetière
de carpentras pour un dernier point sur
le cas de paul oui et pour deux
témoignages que je voudrais vous faire
entendre celui tout d'abord de harlem
désir le président de sos racisme qui a
tenu à se déplacer ici annie almarcha
lui a demandé si cet acte n'était pas
l'illustration de l'échec de la lutte
antiraciste témoignages sévit donc toute
notre société sur le plan moral c'est
une forme d'échec pour l'instant ce sont
des comportements très marginaux je
crois que c'est probablement des esprits
les plus faibles qui se laisse entraîner
à ce genre d'acte mais il ya un contexte
qu'il a favorisé la banalisation de
propos racistes des petites phrases
antisémites qui ont été distillées à
petite dose progressivement de
calembours en négation de l'existence
des chambres à gaz
effectivement on en arrive aujourd'hui à
des comportements odieux et complètement
immoraux et je crois qu'il doit y avoir
d'abord une sanction
exemplaire pour les auteurs dont nous
espérons qu'ils seront évidemment arrêté
mais par ailleurs une réponse éducative
et morale surtout second témoignage
celui de marc ruchmann président de
l'union des étudiants juifs de france
qui a tenu à se déplacer vous comptez
prendre des initiatives
oui totalement avec l'ensemble de la
communauté juive et avec toutes les
organisations antiracistes nous appelons
à une grande manifestation qui ira de la
place de la concorde jusqu'à la
synagogue de la victoire mercredi
prochain à 19h je voudrais dire que
j'appelle vraiment tous les français à
descendre parce que dans ma vie
d'étudiant en tant que militant de
l'union des étudiants juifs de france
c'est la deuxième fois que je ressens
une telle émotion une émotion vraiment
très très profond de la première fois
c'était le détail et là on a assisté
depuis à une banalisation des mots
aujourd'hui on à l'acte attendre at on
assisté à une banalisation des actes en
main est ce que vous avez la tentation
de céder à la violence un mot absolument
pas je crois que ce serait le meilleur
moyen de faire le jeu de ceux qui ont
commis cet acte odieux
mais si marc ruchmann je crois que votre
real et arrêts réaction illustre le
sentiment que tout le monde et prouve
que toute la société française et prouve
que toute la classe politique et pour
vous avez entendu pierre joxe tout à
l'heure c'est l'aveu la classe politique
a le sentiment et le reconnaît d'avoir
joué avec le feu elle fait la promesse
de ne plus s'opposer sur ce terrain miné
qui s'appelle le racisme qui s'appelle
la haine les français ont entendu
aujourd'hui les hommes politiques et
leur rappelleront peut-être cette
promesse faite aujourd'hui deux jours
après cet acte barbare
c'est la fin de l'édition spéciale du
19/20 que nous avons tenu à vous
présenter en direct du cimetière de
carpentras grâce à notre station de
marseille grâce à tdf et grâce à toutes
les équipes de la iii vont soir à lundi
19h ce soir marque hautement à 22h15
bonsoir
tous
de nous